In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinoxadion for June 9, on which we commemorate our venerable father
Cyril of the White Lake.
Our Holy Father Cyril was born in Moscow in 1337 of noble and devout parents and was named
Cosmos at his baptism.
In Orphan he was confided to one of his closest kinsmen, Timothy Veliaminov, an eminent man
at the court of the Grand Prince Demetri.
Prince Timothy, appreciating the intelligence and great qualities of his pupil, soon handed
over to him the management of all his goods.
Despite these honors, Cosmos was sad, because love for the angelic life having been kindled
in his soul.
None of the monasteries he visited dared to receive him for fear of opposition from the
powerful Timothy.
He therefore prayed to God in secret to free him from his attachment to the world and
his vanity.
Having heard that the abbot of the monastery of Makrişke, Makra, blessed Stephen, was coming
to Moscow, Cosmos went to find him and told him with tears of his holy desire.
Stephen clothed him in the monastic habit and changed his name to Cyril, but without
tauntsuring him and went to give Timothy the news.
The latter, in a fury, drove away the man of God with insults, but he soon repented, through
his wives' remonstrances, asked the holy abbots forgiveness, and left Cyril to follow
the path that God was showing him.
Even given all that he had to the poor, Cyril was tauntsured in the monastery of Semenov
by Theodore, nephew of St. Sergeus of Radoniz, and put in the care of a virtuous monk called
Michael, who later became Bishop of Smolensk.
Obedient to his elder, as to God himself, the young monk gave himself with joy to all the
demands of the monastic life, and seized by an impetuous zeal, asked his blessing to
fast more than the other brethren, and only to eat every two or three days.
Michael did not allow him to do so, and ordered him to take his meals at the common table,
but without eating his fill.
He got up at night, and while the elder read the Psalter, Cyril made prostrations until
the beginning of matins.
This night vigil became for the saint more necessary than food and drink, and he never
said it aside, even when he was given the honoris obedience of Baker.
When diabolical apparitions assailed him, especially when his elder was not there, Saint Cyril
banished them with the Jesus prayer and the sign of the cross.
He made such progress of doing all the upsurgings of the flesh that the brethren considered him
more an angel than a man, and when Saint Sergeus came to visit the monastery, he went straight
to the bakery to speak with him of spiritual matters.
Cyril was then transferred to the kitchen, and in front of the red-hot furnace would repeat
incessantly, suffer this fire that you may not be subject to eternal fire.
Fearing, however, the esteem of men, the blessed man pretended to be a fool, joking and laughing
with all who came, so that the abbot made him take dry bread and water every three days.
It was with joy that he received this opportunity to fast, by constraint, and not by my own will.
Once this penance was finished after six months, he desired to devote himself entirely to
prayer in his cell, but, not daring to ask the abbot to release him from his obedience,
he confided his desire to the mother of God.
A few days later, the abbot released him from his work in the kitchen to have him copy
a manuscript.
Cyril gave thanks to the most holy and began his task with great joy, but he quickly realized
that, despite the solitude of life in his cell, his prayer was less profound and less full
of compunction than it had been formerly, and it was with thanksgiving that his task once
completed, he returned to the kitchen, where he labored for nine years.
Having been ordained priest, the saint continued with humble tasks, and when Theodore was made
bishop of Rostov, he had, against his will, to accept the charge of abbot in 1390.
Remaining as humble and gentle as he had been, with no lessening of his Askecies, he directed
the monastery with wisdom, and liberally gave his spiritual councils both to the great
of this world and to the humblest of the faithful, who were drawn in great numbers by his reputation.
Being aware, however, that he risked, losing the monk's greatest good, Isekia, he resigned
his charge, despite the protests of the brethren, and lived in seclusion in his cell.
The result was, however, contrary to his expectation, and he only received yet more glory
from this retreat, which aroused the jealousy of the new abbot.
Saint Cyril, therefore withdrew for a time to a neighboring monastery, dedicated to the
mother of God.
But his soul, avid for contemplation and undistracted prayer, aspired to flee far from men.
One night while he was reciting the acathist hymn, his heart was filled with compunction,
and he heard a voice from heaven saying, Cyril, leave here and go to the white lake, and you
will find rest, for I have prepared there a place for your salvation.
Looking outside, he saw a great light shining to the north in the direction of the white lake.
And with joy he spent the whole night in prayer.
That night was for him brighter than a glorious dawn.
Sometime later he left for this destination, together with Saint Therapontus, one of his spiritual
brethren who had just returned from a stay near the white lake.
Having found the place indicated by the mother of God on a hill set in a thick and deserted
forest, they set across there and began to live the Hessecast life, free of all the
cares of this world.
After a time Therapontus went on a little further to found a monastery.
Cyril then aged sixty was only able to enjoy the complete solitude he desired for a short
time, as two monks from the Simonov monastery who were dear to his heart, Zebedee and Dionysius
came to join him, quickly followed by Nathaniel, who became the community's sellerer.
Although he had at first refused to be their spiritual father, the saint was forced to exceed
to their request, and the brethren built small cells close to his.
One of the men, living in the region, Andrew by name, who had conceived a hatred for the
monks, tried a number of times to set fire to the fence that surrounded the hermit cells,
but through the intervention of the mother of God, they did not take fire.
Andrew became aware of his sin, asked the saint's forgiveness and shortly afterwards became
a monk.
Remembering the Lord's words, him that cometh to me, I will in no wise cast out.
But Cyril, despite his desire for solitude, welcomed all who showed themselves ready to
face the difficulties of this desert place for the love of God.
Of the modest hermit cells, he built a cinematic monastery and then a church dedicated to the
dormitian, with the help of woodcutters, sent by the mother of God.
An avid and violent boyar, called Theodore, thinking that the elderly abbot of Simonov
monastery had brought great wealth with him, sent some rovers at night to rob him.
Arriving near the holy place, the malefactors saw a multitude of archers who guarded it,
unsleepingly.
And the following night there was an even greater crowd, looking like true warriors.
They fled in terror and went to tell the boyar all about it, and he hurriedly sent a servant
to the monastery to see if some noble and powerful personage had been there with his escort.
They answered that no visitor had been for more than a week, realizing then that God and
his angels were guarding the monastery, Theodore went to the saint to confess his wicked plan.
Saint Cyril said to him,
Believe me, Theodore, I have nothing other than this torn habit which you see me wearing,
and a few books.
The rule of life that Saint Cyril had instituted made the monastery like an anti-chamber
of heaven.
In church no one could speak or leave the office before the end.
All the monks stood with fear of God in the place designated for them, following the example
of their Holy Father, who stood like an immovable pillar without leaning against the wall,
even if he was exhausted.
After their simple meal in the Refectory the brothers went to their cells with all work
suspended, there to carry out their rule of prayer as Saint Cyril taught that it is the cell
that teaches the monk everything.
They had all things in common, and they were forbidden to call anything their own or even
pronounce the word money.
Free of all earthly attachment their sole care was to please God and to maintain among themselves
the bond of charity.
If they were in penury the saint encouraged the brethren to keep their trust in God and
forbade them to leave the monastery and go begging.
One of the monks went out once a year to buy all they needed, and if they were sent
alms they were received as a gift of God.
The saint was watchful, moreover to preserve the monastery's Isikia and independence, wanting
it to be poor, and that is why he refused donations of lands or villages in order to leave
the monks free of all earthly trouble or care.
The devil, having stirred up in one of the monks called Theodore, hateful thoughts against
the man of God, he, after a year of struggling, decided to go and confess it, but shame prevented
his speaking.
Endowed by God with the gift of insight, Cyril began to speak with him about thoughts of
hatred, exactly describing his disciples in her state, and avowing to him that he was
a bad man and a sinner.
Feld by the elder's humility the brother threw himself at his feet in tears, and asked his forgiveness,
then went away to his cell in peace.
In many other cases Cyril revealed this gift of insight for the edification of souls and
the correction of sinners.
He had also received the gift of healing that he exercised either by sprinkling the
sick with holy water or anointing them with oil, or even by appearing to them in their sleep,
and he drove demons away with authority.
He even raised a dead man so that he could receive a last communion and die in peace.
But to those whose illness was a punishment for their sins, he refused healing so that their
souls could be saved by this trial.
During a year of famine he gave the order to feed all who went to the monastery, and the
flower increased in the measure to which it was given away.
On another occasion a fire, having broken out, the saint took a cross in his hand and extinguished
it standing in front of the enormous flames.
He wore chains that can still be venerated, and his heart was so filled with divine love
that he could not restrain his tears when he was celebrating the liturgy or at prayer
in his cell.
Saint Cyril's fame, having spread far and wide, the great of this world, wrote to him and
humbly received his advice about the governing of their subjects in conformity with God's
commandments, and the practice of almsgiving for their salvation.
He wrote, for example, to the Grand Prince Basil of Moscow.
In the same way, that on a ship, the defection of a simple roer does not cause much harm, while
that of the captain puts the whole ship in danger.
In the same way, when the prince commits a sin, he harms all who are subject to him.
When the saint, 90 years of age and exhausted by his ascetic labors, felt that the hour was
coming for him to gain his heavenly homeland, he called together his 53 disciples, urged
them to transgress nothing on the cinematic tipicon that he had given them, and designated as
his successor a virtuous man called Innocent, and he then withdrew into silence and prayer.
When he reached his final weakness, while the brethren were lamenting, saying that the monastery
would be deserted after his death, he promised them that he would not abandon them and that
their community would continue to grow as long as they preserved brotherly love.
After having blessed and embraced them, he communicated in the Holy Mysteries and gave his soul
into the Lord's hands while at prayer on the 9th of June in 1427.
His face was immediately illumined and a divine fragrance filled the area.
His precious relics worked many miracles in his monastery which became the high place
of what could be called the Thabayad of the North.
A number of his disciples became famed for the holiness of their lives and founded monasteries
that faithfully observed Saint Cyril's tipicon.
Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.